my name is dan Alcorn I'm on the board
of the Coalition on political
assassinations an organization that we
founded in 1994 to pursue public release
of information about the American
political assassinations first we were
very interested in president john f
kennedy's assassination and then the
assassination of Reverend Martin Luther
King jr. and Senator Robert F Kennedy
and other political assassinations in
the short time that our organization has
been in existence we've had quite an
eventful period the Congress passed
unanimously in 1992 the JFK
assassination records act and that act
has been in implementation during this
period of time there's a federal
organization called the assassination
records Review Board which has had a
two-year life and and we believe will be
extended by Congress for an additional
year so they can continue until
September of next year in order to
process and release documents about the
assassination of President John F
Kennedy quite an enormous amount of
material has come out through that
process we're talking two hundred and
fifty thousand pages released from CIA
files which is the broadest CIA file
release at any time in the history of
that organization and Dwarfs other
releases by that organization and other
federal agencies the FBI has been
turning over a quantity of information
that job is not complete because the
quantity of information is so large the
federal assassination records board has
decided that they need an additional
year to finish their work Congress held
a hearing I guess last week committee
hearing on the topic it looks like
Congress is going to approve an
additional year for the assassination
records Review Board and we think that
that's quite appropriate also during the
period of time that our organization has
existed there's been a lot of public
commentary on the topic of disclosure of
government information and so we have
felt that the past three and a half
years that our organization has worked
three and a half is right little over
three years that we've been in existence
that there's been a lot of progress on
these issues that we're concerned about
but there's a long way to go as well
a recent disclosure that we think is
particularly troubling and instructive
is the disclosure of CIA documents from
the 1954 Guatemalan coup d'etat
operation in which the CIA overthrew the
democratically elected government of the
government of Guatemala sometimes the
stories don't pick up on the fact that
it was a democratically elected
government that we decided overthrow in
1954 and 1,400 pages were released
recently it turns out that these 1,400
pages had been retained by the CIA only
because they were the subject of a
Freedom of Information lawsuit they
would have been destroyed if they had
not been the subject of a FOIA lawsuit
as they ultimately announced many other
records have been destroyed but in this
sort of accidentally preserved 1,400
pages there's a statement and admission
of a CIA assassination program that was
part of the Guatemala coup operation and
this program involved the targeting of
58 political leaders in Guatemala for
assassination by an assassin teams that
were trained in conjunction with the CIA
there was discussion in those records of
the shipping of silencers 422 caliber
rifles from the u.s. to the assassin
team being trained in Honduras for use
in the Guatemala overthrow of 1954 now
the reason that this is so important is
that the CIA did not inform the Congress
of the United States of the existence of
this assassination program when the
Congress investigated the CIA's
involvement in assassinations so that in
1975 when the Congress made an
investigation of this issue they were
not informed of this apparatus that were
now finding from 1953 in 1954 and we
think that that describes the situation
that we're in
in terms of achieving full disclosure
which we support which is that we're
nowhere near full disclosure and we're
still in the process of actually
uncovering what it is that we need to go
after for full disclosure
we're very disturbed that it has
recently been announced in the New York
Times that the CIA has destroyed their
records on the Iran overthrow in 1953
despite the fact that two directors of
Central Intelligence committed to public
release of those records Robert Gates
when he was director committed in 1992
that the CIA would begin to release data
on the Iran overthrow and the Guatemala
overthrow from 1953 and 54 and then when
james woolsey became president clinton's
first CIA director james Woolsey
announced that he would follow through
on that commitment and release these
documents on those operations it has now
been released it has been announced five
years after the commitment that the
reason they've never been released is
that they were destroyed in the early
1960s and then in fact there were no
documents to release and that the
directors of Central Intelligence who
made that commitment were misinformed or
uninformed as to what actually existed
in the CIA this prompted director
Woolsey to make what I think is the
appropriate statement which is this is a
travesty on the history of our country
to have an official of the government go
out and make a commitment like that to
the American people that public
disclosure is going to be made and
openness is going to occur and then have
the records not to exist and allegedly
haven't existed since the early 1960s
and this is the kind of uphill fight
that we have when we're trying to get
full disclosure that you really have to
be very careful about representations
that are made by these government
agencies and organizations as to what's
going to be released and what exists and
so we we have a struggle it is an
important struggle because what is at
stake is what director of the CIA
Woolsey said in the New York Times a
couple of weeks ago which is
this is the history of the country
that's at stake that when these records
are destroyed then we have lost part of
the truthful history of what our country
has done around the world and here at
home over that period of time and so we
think that that makes it very important
that we keep artwork and pushing for
public disclosure and for full
investigation of the documentary record
and try to get as much out as possible
different other things that have
happened in this time we had dr. way and
pepper James Earl Ray's attorney speak
at our conference last year many of you
attended that session and you heard whey
and pepper talk about the Martin Luther
King assassination then in the
intervening time obviously the media has
picked up on the story and it's become
quite a major story around the country
dr. William pepper will be back at our
conference and will be speaking here
tomorrow I believe and so dr. way and
pepper will update us on the Martin
Luther King case finally in something
that I've had some involvement in
there's been a release of information
about the FBI crime laboratory and
indicating that there have been serious
problems in the FBI Crime Laboratory
over an extended period of time which is
something which is not unknown to
assassination researchers in fact I had
first heard of those problems through
people who had researched on the
assassination cases and told me that the
crime lab work didn't look very good in
relation to the assassination issues it
turns out that you don't have to take my
word for it or the word of the
assassination community but why don't
you look at the report of the Inspector
General of the US Department of Justice
who found systemic misconduct in the FBI
crime laboratories so we've had some
things happen since we founded this
organization that we think make the work
of our organization than the existence
of our organization very important and
very important to trying to get an
accurate historical record of this
period in our country this modern period
in our country and that's what we have
been working for and will continue to
work for
now I'm going to introduce our program
chair for our conference he's going to
speak and we'll take questions once
we've made the presentations we'll be
happy to take questions from the press
I'm going to call at this point on Wayne
Smith dr. Wayne Smith he is the program
chair for the conference this year he's
a visiting professor of Latin American
Studies at Johns Hopkins University and
directs an academic exchange program
with the University of Havana he is also
a senior fellow at the Center for
international policy and formerly a
senior associate at the Carnegie
Endowment for international peace he is
a member of the Council on Foreign
Relations
he served 25 years with the Department
of State assigned to the Soviet Union
Argentina Brazil and Cuba was executive
secretary of President Kennedy's Latin
American Task Force and cited as an
outstanding foreign service officer by
his chairman mr. Birrell he was
recognized as the Department of State's
leading expert on Cuba he has published
extensively has several books to his
credit including the Russians are coming
new Soviet policy in Latin America let
me call on our program chair dr. Wayne
Smith Wayne thank you very much Dan let
me say that I do not wish to fly under
any false flags I am NOT one of the
researchers looking into the facts of
this case I came to the assassination
when I was director of Cuban Affairs
back in the end of the 70s and I helped
to arrange the trip of the House Select
Committee to Havana and I became
interested in the assassination at that
point started reading about the
assassination and it was appalled as the
as I got into it to find that the Warren
Commission clearly could not have been
correct and so I joined the Coalition on
political assassinations because I'm
very interested and wanted to be helpful
but I am NOT one of the researchers and
I have not written
any books on the assassination itself I
think we have hi let Sarah McClendon get
settled here and it was hi
welcome we have I think pulled together
a very interesting program this year
and I would urge you all including
members of the press to come back
tomorrow for that three to five panel on
the Martin Luther King assassination
when William pepper will will be here in
addition to others to talk about that
particular case we're also going to have
panels tomorrow morning on the history
and overview of the JFK assassination
some speakers will focus on Lee Harvey
Oswald some of the mysteries surrounding
him and on the forensic evidence panel
three in to some extent panel five will
be on the forensic evidence which I
would say is the core of the case the
coalition of political assassinations
does not base its its doubts or its
rejection outright rejection of the
Warren Commission report on Wilde or
even well-founded theories essentially
it is based on facts I remember an
interview that Dan Rather did some years
ago when he was asked about the Kennedy
assassination and his thoughts on it and
he said well before he had become dan
Rather he had been a crime photographer
in a small town newspaper and so he
always focused on the forensic evidence
and based on that he saw no reason to
believe that the Warren Commission had
been wrong and that the assassination
had not been carried out by a lone
gunman firing from behind well of course
that depends upon the forensic evidence
that you're looking at as we all know
the autopsy report that goes into the
Warren Commission report is not the
original autopsy report the original
autopsy report was destroyed by the
autopsies they themselves have
acknowledged that and they also
destroyed all their notes they also
acknowledge that why did they do that
according to them they didn't want that
original report and the notes to become
memorabilia these are trained doctors it
was supposed to be trained autopsies no
trained doctor would ever destroy his
notes and his original autopsy report on
that basis what goes into the Warren
Commission report is an autopsy report
that has written days later we really
don't know exactly when when it was
written but certainly after Lee Harvey
Oswald had been killed and pointed to as
the lone assassin nothing coming out of
the autopsy room that night
substantiates our supports this second
autopsy report the the artist's
conception that you will see in the in
the Warren Commission report shows a
wound in the back of the neck and the
autopsies of course now say or said at
the time when they wrote the second
autopsy report that the president had
been struck in the back of the neck the
bullet went through the neck exited the
throat and struck governor Connally but
the autopsy diagram they prepared that
night shows the bullet not to have
struck in the back of the neck but to a
struck down in the back six six inches
down in the back the death certificate
places the bullet wound to the left of
the third thoracic vertebra are six
inches down in the back the report
prepared by the two FBI agents who were
in the autopsy room that night also
places the bullet wound six inches down
in the back what difference does it
well a bullet fired on a downward from
above on a downward trajectory striking
in the back is certainly not going to
exit the throat seven inches above I
suppose there's some possibility that it
can strike a rib and do a 90 degree turn
and exit the throat but if so then it
exits on an upward trajectory and
certainly is not going to strike
Connolly how have the autopsies to
explain this discrepancy and their
autopsy diagram that night and the
second autopsy report that they wrote
days later well they actually never have
they've never had to and one of the
reasons that we're waiting anxiously to
see what the review board produces is
because they at last have been deposed
and the autopsies that is have been
deposed and we're anxiously waiting to
see what they said it probably will not
satisfy us I'm sure they haven't said
well actually we perjured ourselves
but it will be it will be very
interesting to see and in any event the
the basis the basis of our rejection of
the Warren Commission the report rests
on many things but most centrally on the
forensic evidence which does not bear
out the Warren Commission report so glad
to see all of you here we hope that
you'll be back at all the panel's
members of the members of the press as
well should I turn the floor over now or
you wish okay Dan we'll sure yeah but
we're going to have we're going to we're
going to and then and then we'll ask
questions okay yeah all right more our
next speaker is dr. Phil Melanson he is
the conference chair this year he's a
professor of political science at the
University of Massachusetts Dartmouth
during the past 15 years he's used
Freedom of Information Act to obtain
documents from the CIA the FBI the
Secret Service and military intelligence
these disclosures
produced a series of exposes and
profiles he is the author of nine books
and 27 articles dealing with
governmental secrecy political violence
intelligence agencies and public policy
issues Melanson has published in such
diverse outlets as the nation Library
Journal transaction society Journal of
politics world teachers newspaper
syndicate and American Political Science
Review he has lectured widely and
appeared or consulted in a number of
television productions his works include
spy saga a book on Oswald's intelligence
connections and the Robert F Kennedy
assassination new revelations on
conspiracy and coverup 1968 to 1991 his
most recent work is shadow play Robert F
Kennedy Sirhan Sirhan an American
justice let me call on dr. Phil Melanson
thank you I'm going to try to highlight
for you some of the things we'll be
doing on the RFK and MLK cases and we
really do have some exciting new
information and some very important
developments in each of those cases
we'll have with us tomorrow dr. William
pepper who as many of you know is James
Earl Ray's lawyer and the dramatic legal
and ballistics evidence results that are
going on in that will be talked to by
dr. peppers as many of you also know
some results of the rifle testing for
the first time have come back it's not
clear to me what that means or what the
legal strategies for reopening the case
will be from here on but we'll get to
hear that firsthand from James Earl
Ray's lawyer and on Wednesday of next
week there will be a court hearing in
Memphis that will solidify or finalize
what's going on with the rifle testing
so it's a very important week in the MLK
case I'm going to highlight for you some
of the developments in the Robert
Kennedy assassination the most dramatic
of which is sore hands their hands
parole hearing coming up next Wednesday
also and that should be a very
interesting event and our hope is that
it will focus not just on the legal
issues but provide some focus on the
evidence issues in the case I will also
report on a writ of habeas corpus put
together by
mr. hands lawyers claiming very
forcefully I think that he did not get a
fair trial to begin with and asking for
another trial there's also the Scott and
iord lawsuit that I reported on last
year that many of you are familiar with
the young photographer who took pictures
that he alleged showed the actual
shooting of Robert Kennedy and we don't
have any such pictures and a jury
awarded him $600,000 in damages
implicitly concluding that LAPD had had
and destroyed those photos and therefore
annuit was entitled to damages and that
is going to be appealed by LAPD and I'll
comment on that let me put in a plug for
the importance of our main conference
team which is full disclosure one of the
exciting things is you'll hear the
reports of what we're getting in the JFK
case thanks to the legislation and the
review board I wish things were as rosy
in the MLK and RFK cases in the RFK case
sir hands lawyer this far from 1968 has
just put together the kind of legal
brief that had the files been released
in 68 or 70 or had disclosure to the
defense taking place at the appropriate
legal and constitutional level there
would have been interesting appeals that
might have changed the legal course of
this case as it is since the files were
secret until a decade ago it's taken
this long for the legal team to put this
information together because the files
were suppressed in the King case we're
still waiting on those approximately 300
I think John John in the King case we
have is about six hundred thousand pages
classified 50 thousand six hundred to
seven hundred fifty thousand pages of
documents still under congressional seal
as were the JFK records and those
records need to come out they're
important for the history of the case
for reinvestigation and they're also
central to James Earl Ray's legal plot
plight for as long as he's alive and
also for the King family's continuing
pursuit of the truth of the murder of
their husband and father which will take
place whether ray dies or not and I
think that's a very dramatic and
interesting development but absent those
documents
which there's no apparent immediacy to
disclose it's going to be much tougher
for anybody to learn the truth and Coppa
is committed to the release of those
files as it was to getting the RFK files
and the JFK files released so I hope you
will stick around with us for these
dramatic and interesting presentations
there's a lot going on even given the
time frame after all these years and
look forward to seeing you thanks I
would also before we take questions I'd
like to recognize John judge who's
executive secretary of Coppa and we very
much appreciate all the work that John
does who really keeps this organization
together so that we can come up here and
do this so thank you we'll take
questions why don't we come up here just
stand up here and go ahead and ask any
questions and direct it to who everyone
I want to ask the question you know that
sirhan program I don't suppose that's a
public hearing is it the pro hearing the
the parole hearing is semi public in
that it's a very small room but my
understanding is that court TV will be
allowed to have one camera there the
rest of the press pool will be
segregated in a different room and CBS
is going and there's still be some big
cameras there but but a lot of them will
have to feed off of Court TV so it will
be public I think it's very limited
access the part that's not public is the
deliberations of the parole board and
I'd have to point out that - - sir -
Sirhan paroles ago the parole board said
let's go make our decision they went
into a room that they thought was
appropriately locked but the recorder
was on broadcasting to the press they
told three off-color jokes joked with
each other about whether they'd stayed
in the room long enough and came out and
gave their verdict so the deliberations
won't be public but the event the event
should be you know I said Corcoran state
prison in Corcoran California about a
hundred miles north of LA that's in the
prison where Sirhan resides that's
really full disclosure
other questions you know Alcorn can you
talk a little bit about what are the
information there baby out there as it
relates to James Earl Ray other than the
bullet of the testing because it's
obvious that they're going to need more
than just a bullet to reopen this case
right and I'm going to let Phil talk on
that too but I think it's almost
importantly not focused so much on the
bullet because there's tremendous amount
of other material and information in
that case and needs to be looked at the
book that way in pepper wrote called
orders to kill is really where you need
to go to look because he's put together
a tremendous amount of information in
the ballistics is only the one piece of
it but what he's put together is that
there was we knew that there was US Army
surveillance on King until the day
before the assassination because the
Memphis commercial appeal newspaper
reported that in an expose three or four
years ago but what way and pepper has
done is taken beyond that he has
confirmed got in touch with the
surveillance team members through the
reporter for the Memphis newspaper and
they say well yes they were also there
on the day of the assassination more
than that they were there on the day of
the assassination that the US Army
military intelligence team he says
photographed the assassination at that
time they were taking photographs of
king surveillance photographs and
photograph the entire event and I think
it's much more crucial to understanding
who did the shooting to try to find
those photographs or any records of
those photographs than to rely entirely
just on the bullet because the
photographs are going to give you
exactly what happened there's a lot more
information in orders to kill but I can
tell you that that if such surveillance
was there and took those photographs the
US government should caught that up
immediately I mean that is the most
relevant information that you can ever
imagine about that crime and the fact
that we know they were there the day
before and they had surveillance on King
for a period of months they were
surveilling him everywhere he went they
bugged his hotel rooms they put him in
the hotel rooms where they wanted him to
stay that had the bugs inserted they
made a range
with the hotels and they had a
wiretapping on the telephones and they
had photo surveillance and I really
think the best way to understand that
event is to have them divulge all the
surveillance they have filled you have
okay well there is no authority for them
to do that and in fact if William pepper
says that the photographs show someone
else shooting King that they show a
rifle extending from the bushes outside
the back of the rooming house in the
restaurant
if the surveillance photographs do in
fact show that then that is evidence
that Ray is not guilty and under the
constitutional standard of Brady versus
Maryland US Supreme Court case that
should have been produced before his
trial at any pendency between now and
should be produced today under the law
in the United States because if the US
government has proved that someone's not
guilty of a crime the law in this
country requires them to produce it
pronto with no complaining
now if the information it's conceivable
that the information may have existed at
one time and been destroyed that's you
know a different situation and we might
try to reconstruct what it is but I have
a feeling that there's still some of
that information in the files yeah I'd
like to emphasize that Ray's lawyer mr.
pepper did not go after the ballistics
test because he thought it was the the
litmus test of guilt or innocence the
most important thing to do he went after
it because it was the only legal Avenue
available to him under the at that time
under Tennessee statute and he wasn't
going going to get a trial full-blown
the case against Ray would not be proved
strong by by the match of that bullet to
the rifle it is very very weak and I
would guarantee that any reasonable jury
looking for reasonable doubt if they
were presented with the absence of
eyewitnesses the absence of fingerprints
where they should be the presence of
other suspects at the crime scene and
the very weak time in motion attributed
to James Earl Ray by the government that
I don't I don't think there's much doubt
that they would find that there was
reasonable doubt in his case secondly
the other part of this is who did it if
James Earl Ray didn't and we're not
talking about non-existent witnesses or
suspects bill pepper presents a list in
his book I present an employee
list in my book they overlap a little
bit they diverge a lot the point is if
you want to bring people in under oath
who might be suspects or our suspects
and might have involved or who might
know who was involved you can do that
and it could be a lengthy and very
productive process so we're not just
talking about cantaloup arisen and
matches here the bullet test is
important but it's only the tip of the
iceberg in in the truth of the the King
case the y ou'll character that mr. rate
continues to says was acting in courts
with them of your speculation on who
this Raoul person might be well I'll
leave that to William pepper tomorrow
because we have different theories on
this which shows that analysts can
disagree I think that there was not one
Raul but a series of composites that Ray
put together pepper on the other hand
not only thinks there was one but he
thinks he's found the one and it is this
Raul character that pepper would present
to the court if he got the opportunity
in a trial among others my understanding
is the Tennessee law permits the private
individuals to bring forward a
prosecutor in a criminal case that
Tennessee is one of only a few states
that permit private criminal
prosecutions and that what may happen
ultimately in this case of the state of
Tennessee does not want to pursue this
case that a group of private citizens
may pursue it under Tennessee law it's a
reason for that for them to destroy the
original autopsy on Kennedy well I think
the reason is because the original
autopsy report would show that the
bullet struck in the back and couldn't
possibly have exited the throat the FBI
agents who were in the room that night
wrote a report on this and they describe
one of the autopsies as probing the back
wound and finding it was only about a
finger deep it was a very light wound
and there not being a bullet he not
having discovered a bullet he speculated
Oh what I wonder what happened to the
bullet during the
autopsy word came from Dallas that they
had found a bullet on a stretcher and
the autopsies then said ah well that
must be the bullet from the back wound
it worked itself out of the wound while
they were working on him in Dallas they
did not they did not examine the wound
in the throat at all they thought that
was simply the result of a tracheotomy
they didn't even look at it and yet a
couple of days later you have the
autopsies saying that it went in the
back of the neck and exited exited the
throat the same bullet that that night
they said must have worked itself out of
the back room of the back wound so if
the original autopsy report had gone in
it would have indicated that the wound
was in the back as their autopsy diagram
showed could not possibly have exited
the throat and therefore could not
possibly have caused the wounds to
Governor Connally and yet the wounds to
governor Connally were real they were
there which means that there had to be
another shooter firing from the rear to
have to have caused those wounds and if
the wound and the throat is not a wound
of exit then it's most likely a wound of
entry which leaves you with a question
as to what happened to the bullet but
given that they performed a tracheotomy
and so forth that is something that that
could perhaps be explained but the
original autopsy report is destroyed
because you couldn't have had the single
gunman firing from the rear theory put
forward but following up on the raw a
little question isn't there some
indication that the House Select
Committee on assassinations a located or
had knew about the whereabouts of Raoul
and hid this information
that's been suggested let me say that
it's known that there are there are a
lot of information on some of the people
that we regard as suspects that is in
House committee files sometimes they
looked at people closer than they
admitted in their final report sometimes
they looked at them not hardly at all
but there's material there didn't end up
in their final report so we really need
that record to sort all that out
somewhat I saw it CNN Headline News last
night a story that they said the defense
team for James our way is requesting
additional tests on the bullet and the
rifles saying that they weren't happy
with the results so far now as far as I
know those results have not been made
public if this be some kind of a leak or
preemptive strike to like discredit if
there is positive proof that the bullet
does not match the rifle you can ask
William pepper tomorrow what his theory
on that is uh because the the real legal
word the definitive word will not come
until Wednesday how that story got out
there I don't know and but I did see it
I don't frankly don't quite understand
it even though I saw it and I'm waiting
for pepper to explain it to me Oh as it
relates to the FBI and Martin Luther
King obviously J Gruber had had his
reasons for wanting to discredit Kay the
King and his in his whole movement can
you a can you address this whole FBI
issue and King in it and it's wanting to
get him and could that have been part of
this whole scenario that brought about
this assassination I'll turn it over to
Phil but when we got the CIA documents
that were released in 1993 as part of
the JFK release there was a package of
documents in there that were related to
the Martin Luther King assassination
they're on plain paper CIA releases they
didn't have a letterhead and there were
reports of surveillance of Martin Luther
King and I told Phil about them and he
got hold of them I think they're in that
BBC documentary that will be played
tonight there's discussion discussion of
it but reading these surveillance
reports of King are a harrowing
experience to read even now because what
was happening was that the both the FBI
and the CIA were focused
King in the spring of 1968 as being a
threat to national security of the
United States because they were
receiving informant reports from an
informant that had been planted in his
entourage a fellow who turns out to be
quite unreliable because he has a
distinct political viewpoint which he
now admits he was embellishing the
reports that were being provided to his
government agencies to give basically
his opinion his personal opinion and he
said he never intended them to take his
comments as fact but you can tell from
the reports that not only did they take
them as fact they circulated them
between the FBI in the CIA and I'll tell
you what the guy was saying what the guy
was saying to them was that Martin
Luther King is an agent of Peking now
known as Beijing but then they spelled
at Peking and that his movement is being
controlled by Peking all right Communist
China if you talk to that guy today he
says well that was my opinion you know
just watching what he did that was what
I thought was going on that I didn't
mean them to take that literally you
know that was just my political
perspective what you can see from these
surveillance reports and the internal
memoranda they took it very seriously
and they were very concerned in the
spring of 1968 that Martin Luther King
was going to lead a movement to
Washington called the poor people's
March it was going to be a follow on to
the march in 63 this was going to be the
poor people's March and they were saying
they were going to come to Washington in
order to raise the issue of poverty in
the United States and is clear that the
Security Agency saw that as a threat in
the summer of 1968 to the functioning of
the government in Washington and saw it
as an attempt to disrupt the gun the
functions of government they went so far
as they had informants in church groups
and they were getting informant reports
from the church groups about how the
King movement was asking for churches in
the Washington area to help put up these
people who were organizing this March
and the CIA was getting reports about
how and actually asked one of the church
boards to have a dispute over whether to
help the March and I have to give credit
to the Unitarian Church in Arlington
they voted 7 to 1
to help the March you know and the CIA
point of view was outvoted seven to one
but as you would read those reports you
realize that in the spring of 68 from
the government's security perspective
that they were in a very defensive and I
would say paranoid state in the spring
of 1968 and what's even more disturbing
to me is that the same unreliable
informant was telling them the Robert F
Kennedy was in the same position and he
his reports are aimed at both Martin
Luther King and Robert Kennedy in that
period of time so yeah I just like to
comment a bit here I think we missed an
important part of our history if we
think that J edgar Hoover's personal
pathology and racism as it was directing
the bureau was the real problem it was a
real problem
the real problem the real story is that
the CIA the FBI and Army Intelligence
according to their own documents
regarded the civil rights movement
generally and Martin Luther King very
particularly as the ultimate national
security communist threat to the United
States and it's in writing and we must
add the Vietnam War to this equation
that in addition to economic justice
which they read as communism now we have
dr. King stridently opposing the Vietnam
War of the year before his death and the
memos going back and forth and saying
now he's really Peking controlled look
what he's saying now he said they've
really got his buttons and this is
dangerous to our national security so
you had a panic situation in which
independently but feeding off of each
other these three powerful intelligence
agencies were zeroing in on Martin
Luther King and we know the two of them
were there at the crime scene and if the
CIA wasn't joining the trilogy I would
be very very surprised so so they may
hold the key to the truth of this matter
more than any of the witnesses when King
repudiated the Vietnam War do you think
that may have tipped the scale I by the
memos it definitely tipped the scale it
went from a worrisome situation of
racial animosity hatred and Prejudice
and fear about economic politics and
racial politics to a major national
security issue and that up the ante
tremendously
any other questions follow us all right
if not thank you very much we appreciate
it we have people here have additional
information about the conference if you
would like it so feel free to ask